While the World Wide Web was initially invented
by one person (see: What was the First Website?),
the genesis of the internet itself was a group
effort by numerous individuals, sometimes
working in concert, and other times independently.
Its birth takes us back to the extremely competitive
technological contest between the US and the
USSR during the Cold War.
The Soviet Union sent the satellite Sputnik
1 into space on October 4, 1957. Partially
in response, the American government created
in 1958 the Advanced Research Project Agency,
known today as DARPA—Defense Advanced Research
Projects Agency. The agency’s specific mission
was to
…prevent technological surprises like the
launch of Sputnik, which signaled that the
Soviets had beaten the U.S. into space. The
mission statement has evolved over time. Today,
DARPA’s mission is still to prevent technological
surprise to the US, but also to create technological
surprise for our enemies.
To coordinate such efforts, a rapid way to
exchange data between various universities
and laboratories was needed. This bring us
to J. C. R. Licklider who is largely responsible
for the theoretical basis of the Internet,
an “Intergalactic Computer Network.” His
idea was to create a network where many different
computer systems would be interconnected to
one another to quickly exchange data, rather
than have individual systems setup, each one
connecting to some other individual system.
He thought up the idea after having to deal
with three separate systems connecting to
computers in Santa Monica, the University
of California, Berkeley, and a system at MIT:
For each of these three terminals, I had three
different sets of user commands. So if I was
talking online with someone at S.D.C. and
I wanted to talk to someone I knew at Berkeley
or M.I.T. about this, I had to get up from
the S.D.C. terminal, go over and log into
the other terminal and get in touch with them….
I said, oh man, it’s obvious what to do:
If you have these three terminals, there ought
to be one terminal that goes anywhere you
want to go where you have interactive computing.
That idea is the ARPAnet.”
So, yes, the idea for the internet as we know
it partially came about because of the seemingly
universal human desire to not have to get
up and move to another location.
With the threat of a nuclear war, it was necessary
to decentralize such a system, so that even
if one node was destroyed, there would still
be communication between all the other computers.
The American engineer Paul Baran provided
the solution to this issue; he designed a
decentralized network that also used packet
switching as a means for sending and receiving
data.
Many others also contributed to the development
of an efficient packet switching system, including
Leonard Kleinrock and Donald Davies. If you’re
not familiar, “packet switching” is basically
just a method of breaking down all transmitted
data—regardless of content, type, or structure—into
suitably sized blocks, called packets. So,
for instance, if you wanted to access a large
file from another system, when you attempted
to download it, rather than the entire file
being sent in one stream, which would require
a constant connection for the duration of
the download, it would get broken down into
small packets of data, with each packet being
individually sent, perhaps taking different
paths through the network. The system that
downloads the file would then re-assemble
the packets back into the original full file.
The platform mentioned above by Licklider,
ARPANET was based on these ideas and was the
principle precursor to the Internet as we
think of it today. It was installed and operated
for the first time in 1969 with four nodes,
which were located at the University of California
at Santa Barbara, the University of California
at Los Angeles, SRI at Stanford University,
and the University of Utah.
The first use of this network took place on
October 29, 1969 at 10:30 pm and was a communication
between UCLA and the Stanford Research Institute.
As recounted by the aforementioned Leonard
Kleinrock, this momentous communiqué went
like this:
We set up a telephone connection between us
and the guys at SRI… We typed the L and
we asked on the phone,
“Do you see the L?”
“Yes, we see the L,” came the response.
We typed the O, and we asked, “Do you see
the O.”
“Yes, we see the O.”
Then we typed the G, and the system crashed…
Yet a revolution had begun.
By 1972, the number of computers that were
connected to ARPANET had reached twenty-three
and it was at this time that the term electronic
mail (email) was first used, when a computer
scientist named Ray Tomlinson implemented
an email system in ARPANET using the “@” symbol
to differentiate the sender’s name and network
name in the email address.
Alongside these developments, engineers created
more networks, which used different protocols
such as X.25 and UUCP. The original protocol
for communication used by the ARPANET was
the NCP (Network Control Protocol). The need
for a protocol that would unite all the many
networks was needed.
In 1974, after many failed attempts, a paper
published by Vint Cerf and Bob Kahn, also
known as “the fathers of the Internet,”
resulted in the protocol TCP (Transmission
Control Protocol), which by 1978 would become
TCP/IP (with the IP standing for Internet
Protocol). At a high level, TCP/IP is essentially
just a relatively efficient system for making
sure the packets of data are sent and ultimately
received where they need to go, and in turn
assembled in the proper order so that the
downloaded data mirrors the original file.
So, for instance, if a packet is lost in transmission,
TCP is the system that detects this and makes
sure the missing packet(s) get re-sent and
are successfully received. Developers of applications
can then use this system without having to
worry about exactly how the underlying network
communication works.
On January 1, 1983, “flag day,” TCP/IP
would become the exclusive communication protocol
for ARPANET.
Also in 1983, Paul Mockapetris proposed a
distributed database of internet name and
address pairs, now known as the Domain Name
System (DNS). This is essentially a distributed
“phone book” linking a domain’s name
to its IP address, allowing you to type in
something like todayifoundout.com, instead
of the IP address of the website. The distributed
version of this system allowed for a decentralized
approach to this “phone book.” Previous
to this, a central HOSTS.TXT file was maintained
at Stanford Research Institute that then could
be downloaded and used by other systems. Of
course, even by 1983, this was becoming a
problem to maintain and there was a growing
need for a decentralized approach.
This brings us to 1989 when Tim Berners-Lee
of CERN (European Organization for Nuclear
Research) developed a system for distributing
information on the Internet and named it the
World Wide Web.
What made this system unique from existing
systems of the day was the marriage of the
hypertext system (linked pages) with the internet;
particularly the marriage of one directional
links that didn’t require any action by
the owner of the destination page to make
it work as with bi-directional hypertext systems
of the day. It also provided for relatively
simple implementations of web servers and
web browsers and was a completely open platform
making it so anyone could contribute and develop
their own such systems without paying any
royalties. In the process of doing all this,
Berners-Lee developed the URL format, hypertext
markup language (HTML), and the Hypertext
Transfer Protocol (HTTP).
Around this same time, one of the most popular
alternatives to the web, the Gopher system,
announced it would no longer be free to use,
effectively killing it with many switching
to the World Wide Web. Today, the web is so
popular that many people often think of it
as the internet, even though this isn’t
the case at all.
Also around the time the World Wide Web was
being created, the restrictions on commercial
use of the internet were gradually being removed,
which was another key element in the ultimate
success of this network.
Next up, in 1993, Marc Andreessen led a team
that developed a browser for the World Wide
Web, named Mosaic. This was a graphical browser
developed via funding through a U.S. government
initiative, specifically the “High Performance
Computing and Communications Act of 1991.″
This act was partially what Al Gore was referring
to when he said he “took the initiative
in creating the Internet.” All political
rhetoric aside (and there was much on both
sides concerning this statement), as one of
the “fathers of the internet,” Vincent
Cerf said, “The Internet would not be where
it is in the United States without the strong
support given to it and related research areas
by the Vice President [Al Gore] in his current
role and in his earlier role as Senator…
As far back as the 1970s, Congressman Gore
promoted the idea of high speed telecommunications
as an engine for both economic growth and
the improvement of our educational system.
He was the first elected official to grasp
the potential of computer communications to
have a broader impact than just improving
the conduct of science and scholarship…
His initiatives led directly to the commercialization
of the Internet. So he really does deserve
credit.” (For more on this controversy,
see: Did Al Gore Really Say He Invented the
Internet?)
As for Mosaic, it was not the first web browser,
as you’ll sometimes read, simply one of
the most successful until Netscape came around
(which was developed by many of those who
previously worked on Mosaic). The first ever
web browser, called WorldWideWeb, was created
by Berners-Lee. This browser had a nice graphical
user interface; allowed for multiple fonts
and font sizes; allowed for downloading and
displaying images, sounds, animations, movies,
etc.; and had the ability to let users edit
the web pages being viewed in order to promote
collaboration of information. However, this
browser only ran on NeXT Step’s OS, which
most people didn’t have because of the extreme
high cost of these systems. (This company
was owned by Steve Jobs, so you can imagine
the cost bloat… ;-))
In order to provide a browser anyone could
use, the next browser Berners-Lee developed
was much simpler and, thus, versions of it
could be quickly developed to be able to run
on just about any computer, for the most part
regardless of processing power or operating
system. It was a bare-bones inline browser
(command line / text only), which didn’t
have most of the features of his original
browser.
Mosaic essentially reintroduced some of the
nicer features found in Berners-Lee’s original
browser, giving people a graphic interface
to work with. It also included the ability
to view web pages with inline images (instead
of in separate windows as other browsers at
the time). What really distinguished it from
other such graphical browsers, though, was
that it was easy for everyday users to install
and use. The creators also offered 24 hour
phone support to help people get it setup
and working on their respective systems.
Berners-Lee
chose the name “World Wide Web” because
he wanted to emphasize that, in this global
hypertext system, anything could link to anything
else. Alternative names he considered were:
“Mine of Information” (Moi); “The Information
Mine” (Tim); and “Information Mesh”
(which was discarded as it looked too much
like “Information Mess”).
Pronouncing “www” as individual letters
“double-u double-u double-u” takes three
times as many syllables as simply saying “World
Wide Web.”